today's guest is a musician
um an entertainer
and really is a smoo really just a
smooth criminal honestly
uh he's one of the most infectious
human beings that i've been around and
i'm grateful for you guys to get to hear
his story
uh today's guest is jelly roll
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
just
bender it is baby
uh
the song what is it you got uh dead man
walking it's the number five song on
rock radio it's called dead man walking
it's [ __ ] crazy i've never had a song
on radio ever gang baby so yeah it's big
[ __ ] is that crazy it's weird yeah but
in a cool way oh yeah like as a kid i
don't care who you are especially like
my age group you dream of having a song
on the radio so having one on the radio
is like surreal you know that is kind of
a thing when you're young man and you
hear that radio
it always seemed like it was it would be
impossible to get your song to come out
of it i bet oh yeah imagine being a
little white trash kid like me and you
and you're wondering how it's coming
through the radio anyways you're looking
around like there's no cord on the car
yeah i was just even coming through
right now yeah yeah almost like they
were sitting inside of your motor and
playing for you personally yeah
dude i used to have a dream that um
that at one point in automobiles they
would have a
a disc or something you'd put into the
dashboard right and then the band they'd
have like hologram i always had this
vision that hologram was really going to
pop off
and the band would come out onto your
dashboard the way it would be built and
the band would perform right there for
you right there yeah god we should still
make that i could be if i could make
money i could make some wrecks yeah yeah
sure first day i smoke a dubia and look
over there and see hendrick's shredding
i'm [ __ ] crashing
yeah somebody's just somebody's just
locked in on wiz khalifa they can't even
handle it
no it's cool man so what was that for
you for like me as a kid it was like
radio was like the thing like you won
like as an artist you wanted to have a
song on the radio now i haven't so
what's for you was it like
i guess did you come up like the disc
comedy era like you wanted a comedy
album or was it like comedy central or
yeah getting on comedy central was big
doing that and um
getting the album out and getting it on
the itunes charts was real big you know
uh i remember
um 30 pounds of hamster bones was like
my first real album release and and that
got onto the like i think we i think we
got to number one at some point you
notice based on the way the sales go
and so that was pretty wild um
but i remember my first do you remember
the first song you ever heard through
the radio
oh man
probably not the first song i ever heard
through the radio i know the first like
album we wouldn't bought or like
cassette tape my sister bought yeah but
i can't think of like the first song i
heard on the right you remember the
first song you like remember hearing on
the radio yeah i remember i had a uh
my mom had
some
um
some
uh like
babysitters took us to summer camp right
so they'd come pick us up in the morning
and they would take us
and this one lady picked me up i feel
like her name was heather but i don't
know
but she picked me up man and she they
had bon jovi she had playing and i'd
never
i think cause there was a woman involved
also there was like a babysitter and she
was like hot and she like had tits and
everything and so like
i i remember it was uh
what was um what was one of those bon
jovi hits
it was uh
what was like one of his biggest most
popular songs oh [ __ ] dude i just woke
up and i'm high oh dad
i haven't even ate breakfast and i'm
stoned and i'm sitting here with theo
talking about bon jovi i'm like [ __ ]
this is wow i'm on the radio and theo's
telling me about bon jovi
i would i would like to touch on heather
for a second though oh i would have
liked to as well brother baby i'll tell
you that
i think we all have a first teacher as
dudes that we like mine was my
kindergarten teacher i don't remember my
first grade teacher second grade teacher
third fourth fifth no no but i remember
my kindergarten teacher's name was
harris and that is when i knew i liked
asses
she had the fats not the flats i mean
she had boy that thing man
she had a monkey on her back dog real
doubled up huh listen i remember going
home my brother had to explain to me
what i was feeling i was like i think
you could pop it i was like you know as
a kid i was like my brother was like oh
yeah you're gonna like asses when you're
older oh flew over my head then oh yeah
later oh dude my wife's got miss
harris's ass to the tee hey
school's in session
i put an apple right between them cheeks
for you it was heather for me it was
miss harris dude i remember and she i
would always be like hey can i put your
seatbelt on for you all the time
we'd be in the car and uh
and i think we had to sit in the back
but i'd be like can i put your seatbelt
on for you and she would just take it
off and i would like reach across
like put that seat belt on
oh it made me feel so listening to bob
jovi yeah yeah
i wish i could remember that song man it
was uh
but anyway it was one of his hits man
but yeah for my listeners that don't
know about you man so how so you guys
start to take me through the story man
your story is is a really inspirational
one and also
you just have this infectious energy man
i just noticed it anytime i'm around you
i wish i was you all right dude thank
you i feel the same way about you that
guy is having so much fun
like i want to be that guy
i love you man thank you brother yeah
you bet man you got that tan man that's
why i'm [ __ ] blowing it
you think you spraying that thing on man
are you laying in the bed or whatever
dude i just went to damn uh
i don't know you were fishing oh yeah i
was fishing i just seen happy belated
birthdays oh thanks [ __ ] way to spend
the birthday dog dude you're too kind
man that was with the jimmy john by the
way like the jimmy john jimmy johnson
yeah do we went out there it was like we
caught
i mean you go out there and it's night
like the vessel is damn nice dude i got
to it was like noah was on that [ __ ]
you know i'm saying it was damn dude
they had animals trying to get on fish
we're trying like damn this looks nice
dog you know you see all these mexican
fish we're like hey
give us a ride back to freaking cuba you
know like they had fish jumping on that
and panthers were getting on that [ __ ]
they had animals i didn't even know
existed out there trying to get in it
was a luxury boat right so you're out on
there and they had a couple they got
like some
fishermen like men that are just
you know just a couple damn moby dick
lurkers out there and then [ __ ] they
show up and so they put in sometimes if
you're in like the deep water they have
the these big electric
uh rod and reels on the sides and they
would cast those down to like
1500 feet or something
so you would just cast them down and
then you would see the thing go like
that you know and so you were pressing
these buttons instead of doing reeling
oh [ __ ] it's like playing an xbox for
fishing yeah yeah it was
that's [ __ ] well i mean it was like
you could catch the past you have
memories come up if somebody pulled up a
memory of something when you were a kid
you're like damn that was deep bro
so that was almost like i was like is
that the real jimmy john that's him
maybe a sandwich jockey dude he um
yeah that man turkey timed his way in
there you know what's [ __ ] up i look
at you and i get jealous because i'm
like you have all the friends i want but
don't need it's like todd graves is your
homie too from county right i'm like i'm
already fat i'd be like i'd die if i had
your friend list right now i'd just like
live in a house full of sandwiches and
fried chicken
i'm like he's got every you're cool with
everybody i want to be cool with but god
knows i don't need to be cool yeah i've
got some of those people i'm not even
going to introduce you to man just i
seen you i seen y'all carrying the jimmy
john sandwiches on i was like [ __ ] me in
honor of your veins on behalf of your
veins i'm gonna say i'm not introducing
you to those dogs especially not the
chicken man yeah
oh yeah man i've been pretty lucky and
those are the guys that have just come
on the podcast and then you kind of get
to you know have a relationship with
them or become friends with them um but
that was unbelievable and then there's
some points where you get a rod and reel
and you're actually doing the fishing
you know and it's like an industrial
size it's like something they'd sell at
home depot oh dude i just think about
the distance from what looked like where
you were at on the boat to the water
yeah it wasn't like when you're sitting
on like the little you know like the
little boat in the bayou you probably
used to get on where you just kind of
tip your little toe in the water i mean
it looked like it was a full-blown dive
we nobody touched the wall i was at one
point i jumped in for like 30 seconds
because they had some real bad sharks in
there and uh but you couldn't reach out
and touch the boat yeah you touched the
water yeah it looked like you were high
as [ __ ] yeah you were and then you go
inside and you're like in a damn
marriott plus or something
you know that [ __ ] how many days were
you sleeping on the water and everything
yeah you go to sleep out there dude it's
like being it's like being in somebody's
it's like being i feel like in a just
like in a damn black lady's womb
did you sleep good or did the rock and
[ __ ] with you the rocking sleep put me
out it's like being on a bus without the
sound of the engine oh yeah it's like
furniture's all made out of percocet
baby falls straight to sleep on that
[ __ ] son i was out and it was his boat
as jimmy john's boat yeah yeah it's
jimmy john boat man so that was awesome
he took me it was my birthday so he took
me out there and so we we flew out on
friday
uh straight down to bahamas and then we
uh jumped on the boat yeah there's some
dude like an island guy like you want
the uh
roast beef
they don't even have a junior for a
thousand miles
you're sitting there with jimmy with a
box of
listen jimmy john this is for you uh
would you please bring back the chicken
caesar rap it was fire it was it was
limited time only and i think the time
was too limited sir you'd like to pray
in fact man or use your influence to
help you boy man it'd mean a lot to me
we'll see look i'll put that word in
baby i'll send that
i'll send that off the ladder that's the
only promo clip i want from the day it's
me asking jimmy john to bring a
discontinued sandwich back hey i think
we could i think we could help i [ __ ]
hate you i think we could help man
um
so how did you find parker we were just
talking off camera about how much yeah
you know how does theo find music that's
what i'm really getting at here oh
that's all right and then i want to
learn about how you got into music man
because i want i really want my audience
to know that and uh
i you know what i do man i'm on tick
tock man yeah they got this uh they got
this fella four track that i'll listen
to i think he's out of south carolina is
that the guy you came out to the other
night at the comedy club yes yes that
[ __ ] was bang and yeah i don't know who
it was can you pull it up see if you can
get him on here
[Music]
gang gang baby
hunamo rash another gun in iraq
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you was telling the sound guy it was
like you play this song and i think i
asked you afterwards you came out i was
like your song was fire who is he's like
four track i was like
how are you you're like i just found
them like i just like
just found them that's tick tock look
man when you don't have a family or
nothing bro you tick-tock at night by
yourself and you come across a little
foreign tick-tock's so popular now you
do that when you have a family yeah
they're sad nor if some nights i lay in
the wife of my bed we're just watching
two separate tick
feeds there just
you guys are tock
uh inadvertently hooked on walker hayes
i know it's like hell i'm just watching
fancy like on repeat like i'm being like
i'm being like i'm finally getting
punished for my sins of life
uh how do i find some music that's
probably how i got actually my buddy i
was telling you that story my buddy uh
whenever you back in the day when you
would just you know ejaculating was a
big thing you know
now it's kind of like all over the place
it feels like you know so much
pornography back in the day you had to
really you know i remember we'd buy a
drawing of some cooter or something you
know for the weekend you know we had
this buddy we had this dude nicky would
sell us a little sketch just a little
bit of cooter for the weekend and we'd
take that [ __ ] home on friday and bring
it back on monday you know because you
got two dollars back if you brought it
back yeah you had to piece your own
magazine together where this guy had a
page from this one and this guy had a
page from this one you take three four
pages and tape them together be your own
kind of magazine
wouldn't be a playboy you know it
actually had
this is my [ __ ] but my buddy scott would
put a map up in his car he's riding with
his folks one time he puts a map up in
the car because at that age if you start
masturbating that's the thing it gets
you hooked the devil gets you hooked on
your own dick
and you just start bro you're sitting
there man and my buddy scott did it
he was just telling his family where
they were going and the whole time he's
behind this map
just ruining maine that's all he was
doing and i thought i was a gangster
because i could pull it sometimes if my
cellmate was asleep when i was in jail
and even then i felt pretty sketchy
because there was another grown man
there but could you imagine just having
a carpool
your sister's in the back seat kicking
the seat that's family
where's steve harvey when that shit's
going down you know bring that question
up you're over there adding tributaries
to your own freaking map
um
so take me through man so how do you so
how do how did you get into music man
how did it start for you when you're
coming up where does the music hit you
first in your life
my mother was probably like
the sad part of the story is my mother
always struggled with mental health
issues and addiction and she didn't
leave much at all when i was a kid she
was a recluse she never really left the
house and uh
she would like her making it to the
kitchen table was kind of like a big
deal you know yeah and you'd walk in the
house and mom would be at the kitchen
table and she'd have a cigarette lit and
she'd be sitting on a wood chair indian
style right there in the kitchen back
when you could smoke it but back when
restaurants had smoking sections smoking
inside places was a thing you know and
she'd be there smoking a cigarette and
she'd have a record plan
and she'd just have her eyes closed and
i just i could tell that the music was
doing something to her man
like i just remember watching her and
thinking man this music's like
whatever that is is
helping her you know or she'd play like
bette midler the rose and cry
i could i could still hear in my head
play this at my funeral to this day if
you play bette midler the rose right now
i might tear up and she plays my funeral
uh jelly place my funeral baby jason she
just smoked cigarette
and i just remember thinking man i want
to make people feel the way this makes
my mother feel
that's the songwriting aspect of it
right that was what
ignited the songwriter in me
now the influences are cool because i
was the baby right i was the youngest
how many uh two brothers one sister and
my sister who she's still with to this
day was within so she's been with this
man 30 something years he pretty much
lived with us from her high school years
up so i say i had three brothers two
brothers a brother-in-law that lived
with us and a sister and we always had
some broke cousin on the couch or some
broke family and you know in the living
room with blow up mattresses or
something this was just like future
convict yeah this is our current convict
or somebody on the run from the police
we had that kind of a house
and
we would like yeah when hide and go seek
was hidden goes
for sure i'll tell you a story about
that in a second it's even better but
when i got in the car with anybody
because i was the baby i had no [ __ ]
control of the radio dial i was the last
[ __ ] that got to pick the radio
oh yeah right it was so important you
got
who got
radio right
so it's like when i was in the car i had
one brother that listened to nothing but
gangster at musical sitting here is
awesome because he's met my whole family
yeah um we got tour manager bizzle
gibbons is sitting here in the in the
studio throw him in the middle of our
[ __ ] because looking at him like he's
looking over there like yeah i met most
of him i had one brother named scott
that's the middle older that was a
straight gangster rap guy like tupac
biggie like gangster gang the gang's the
more gangster the better well was he
dating white chick still or how gangster
was he i mean no he was everywhere
yeah his dick didn't discriminate
yeah he got that yeah for sure he was
all about it all and and we lived in a
super mixed neighborhood anyway so it
was just super common to you know like
all my brothers had a black best friend
or something it was just so many you
know whatever yes neighbors were black
we had a chinese guy in the neighborhood
mexicans dude we had an iranian family
down at the bottom of the street that
were super savage dude they'd bring
iranian food up dude iraqi food and it
was [ __ ] fire dude but
anyways so i'm sorry i'm [ __ ] high
but
we get in the car and like all these
different radio states will play so like
one brother be gangster rap my sister
listen like nothing but metallica or
stone temple pilots yeah for sure like
[ __ ] nirvana when they first came out
this was all oh yeah and then i had
another brother listening like super hip
hop [ __ ] like biz marquis kind of [ __ ]
yeah and then dad would listen to either
jazz or back then like singer songwriter
stuff like james taylor jim croce um my
mother listened to motown oldies and
like outlaw country music damn so it's
like every room i'd walk into or every
[ __ ] everywhere i'd go it'd be some
different music playing so when people
like dude you kind of do all kinds of
music i'm like i'm a [ __ ] human
jukebox man i grew up in a you know i
didn't get to pick up music i liked and
get to play it because i didn't [ __ ]
you know everybody else had their genre
of music in their world but me
i didn't have like a place i could go
listen to what i wanted right right
right i just had to listen to whatever
[ __ ] room i walked in yeah that's
funny the younger brother is kind of you
kind of that that ear victim bro you
know it's like whatever you kind of you
start to get into whatever anybody else
is into that's i never thought about
that the older brother really gets to
pick the radio and that kind of shapes
the younger brother a little bit sure
it's like if my brother's listening to
uh dr dre then i'm all draid up i'm
buying that t-shirt with the weeds 100
and when he switches to nirvana dude i'm
f you know i'm cutting my wrist but not
with sharp silverware yeah yeah yeah i
didn't get to get in the car and be like
i really want to listen to 107.5 the
river nobody gave a [ __ ] what i want to
listen to you know like we didn't know
you could talk i tell you the first
cassette tape i ever got given
i got all these gifts for christmas and
then they were like we got one last gift
from you and this is from your bro this
is from your brothers and sisters i was
like oh this is probably the coolest
gift ever and they gave me a little
bitty package and it was a cassette tape
and it was rex and effects rump shaker
yeah
and i was like this is gangster and i
remember at that moment it was something
that was finally mine because they some
mama had bought me a boom box
and daddy bought me a boombox but nobody
i didn't have nothing to play in it yet
yeah so then my brother and they did the
coolest thing besides that and then this
then they when they hand me the wrecks
and effects tape then they handed me
five blank cassette tapes
i said what are these for they were like
we're gonna show you how to record songs
off the radio you remember this era oh
right when you put the cassette tape in
listen for all of y'all that want to
know how old i am i'm that [ __ ] old
top 10.
yeah you go to the top 10 and you'd wait
and wait for the perfect moment for the
song to start then you hit the play and
record button you got to get it just
right because you didn't want to hear
the radio dj or the skip you want to
just decide that you stop right there
yeah and you play it for one more second
so there was a space between the two
songs and then you'd hit it again you
know are you calling requests a song
that wasn't popular yet you'd have to
wait for hours for them to play it
they're like who's this donkey and they
taught me that so i started making like
mixed cassette tapes and i knew i was on
to something different then because like
i'd get in the car and find out i got a
cassette tape everybody we don't care
about you can set her but please play it
and it would like go from like rap to
something else and the brother was like
what the [ __ ] is up like well shelby
taught me about this song so everybody
got happy
so you really were you really were like
a jukebox yeah oh to this day man you
play very few songs and i'm not like
yeah i know that error
do you have a body do you have balls
do you have do you have a body with
balls on it well our friends at manscape
the global leader and below the waist
hygiene are turning men's shower dreams
into their favorite routine
with the all-new ultra premium
collection
it's the all-in-one hygiene skin and
hair bundle designed to upgrade every
day man's shower routine
from head to toe your skin hair and
balls
deserve this save big by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with code t-h-e-o
that's right
they have cologne infused ultra premium
body wash
they have shampoo conditioner
deodorant
hydrating moisturizer spray
lip balm
everything they take care of you
that's right
and they're using the lawnmower electric
trimmer to clean off any unwanted body
hair that's included
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code theo at
manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the code theo at manscape.com it's time
to get wet and clean
with your new manscaped shower routine
ball up
with more folks hitting the road more
accidents are happening and insurance
rates are going up
lucky for us our friends at the zebra
are here to help
they make it easy to save hundreds on
car home insurance save your money man
you spend an extra dollar saving bro
don't be an idiot the zebra compares
home and car quotes from every insurance
company
side by side giving you all the facts
you need to make the right decision
the zebra saves people an average of 922
a year you could buy a damn boat with
that
uh they save on car and home insurance
combined
dude last year i would look at my home
and ship my insurance man i was spending
i can't even tell you how much
not a ton but it was like 60 extra
dollars a month and i saved it
save time and money in minutes you can
do it show your support for the show by
going to this special url the zebra.com
t-h-e-o and get your free quote today
that's at the zebra.com slash theo
so what so what was the family life like
what was it what was it like growing up
were you guys like uh so you had a mom
and you all had a stepdad or no step no
i had a father oh you got a dad best
friend in the world sweetest dude on
earth he uh taught me that's right buddy
was your dad right but it was my yeah
i've heard stories about it he is a
[ __ ] legend
he really is dude old school gangster
just laid back
um storyteller but softly spoke and
didn't talk nearly as much as me but
said a lot more and he was an old-school
gangster like that but uh dad and mother
were together whenever i was younger
they divorced in my earlier teenage
years and
why they divorce you think oh [ __ ] dude
you know frankly mom you know god i love
her today i'm sorry if you're watching
this birdie but she uh you know she just
she dealt with so much of her own [ __ ]
man i just i couldn't i don't
who she is now and who she was in are
two different people so i'm sure she
won't be offended by this i couldn't
have been with her yeah you know what i
mean who she was back then i mean he was
pushing the square through a circle for
a long time you know
she was really struggling i mean i'm
talking about a woman that i didn't see
not wearing a nightgown for 15 years oh
wow you know what i mean like i don't
have a memory of her being like in a
kindergarten thing or you know what i
mean like none of that [ __ ] damn so that
must have left you feeling almost like i
mean if your mom wasn't showing up for a
lot of stuff he probably left you
feeling kind of
unseen or something sometimes first
no judgment against your mom look yeah
my mom struggles with a lot of that and
so it's just they went through it so
somebody did it you know they went
through it yeah in their era you know
now that i'm old enough i look back at
her and go man she grew up in a house
with three other sisters she she grew up
with a single mother my mother's 73
years old so if you think about her
growing up with a single mother raising
four kids she was the town [ __ ] in
everybody's eyes yeah that's normal now
you see a [ __ ] at the grocery store
right now with five kids and be like
[ __ ] she must be from antioch yeah you
know what i'm saying it's like you seen
it back then i was like you're [ __ ]
hard you know what i mean you damn hard
you know looking forward yeah yeah you
know it's like totally different world
so i mean i kind of get where she came
from and her mother which was my granny
was just just [ __ ] mean as a [ __ ]
beaver on meth she was just a [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying she was mean
dude and i knew that about her so you
know i get i get what you know her
issues but yeah they had divorced but
pops was a pops ran a meat company for
years he's like oh damn what kind of
meat dude we got three generations of
meat salesmen oh really dude i can tell
you more about a pig than i can tell you
about [ __ ] and i know a little bit
about both and i'm telling you man it's
just some dude he was uh my grandfather
was ran a meat truck called d ford
sausage company and then my father took
it over and it was called deford
wholesale meats
and they changed llc's huh yeah yeah
well you know dad got into the wholesale
business you know my my grandfather was
old enough that they actually rode
around in a truck and went door to door
this is back when the closest grocery
store to a neighborhood was 15 20
minutes away and it was a buy writer or
c.b smith
yeah this is long before walmart so you
know you probably grew up in an area
where the meat trucks came to the
neighborhood yeah you know well we had i
remember they had a dude it was
schwann's truck or something yeah and
this dude would roll through and this
dude honestly was banging some ladies
bro this i don't know how this guy was a
real casanova bro you know what i'm
saying he would the second he saw the
kids he'd be all pissed and stuff you
could tell
but um he was yeah they had everything
in there fro like frozen things of
cookies and uh beef he had the beef area
he had to get in the beef area
uh the beef fairy i remember when you
opened that [ __ ] up it was like oh yeah
all the
it was so cold in there as a child you
couldn't even look in there for long he
was afraid to even look at the beef and
then he they they came through with the
little chinese food portal at one point
and that's when i think the people i was
living with at the time they cut it off
man they said we're not doing all of
this yeah well at that point it wasn't
far away from being food trucks in that
area but yeah it was like an early food
truck but you had to cook it yeah for
sure no but yeah
big beauford my grandfather would just
pull up with a and he did nothing but
pork it was just sausage it was a
defored sausage company it's a family
recipe
we still have it to this day and uh
my father was entrepreneurial so he was
like i want to sell more than pork so he
got into poultry and beef oh dad as well
and he was like instead of taking it
door-to-door changed with the times i'm
not just gonna service door-to-door in
the small piggly wigglies and buy rights
i'm gonna start going to local barbecue
pits and local restaurants that were
local owned and local red and you know
he was a he sold meat that way and
and and housed his own meat my brother
now my oldest brother
the one that was more of a hip-hop head
um
he's still in the meat business
yeah oh dude it's still you know it
tickles me pink because it's like my
dad's still here i go hang out my
brother and all his meat salesman
friends yeah
it's funny how that business is
generational that way because most of
them guys you'll meet daddy was in the
meat business you know
a lot of businesses are yeah it's crazy
the police officers boat captains a lot
of things are
it just comes down through the family
line i was the only one that had a
vision outside of anything like that my
other brother ended up doing a
uh survey he's a land surveyor uh
and does all that kind of stuff he's
like uh into like engineering and stuff
civil engineering yeah i actually got my
degree in urban planning bro um
an urban planning
yeah i'm a uh
i'm an urban planner i guess i mean i am
i'm i don't know i don't know if i'm a
licensed exactly or whatever i don't
know if i ever got a license but i am
i guess i'm legally an urban planner i
guess i mean i got the you know i did it
you know i think it's mostly about
i mean i know what it's about it's about
neighborhoods like if you have to have
like uh say you're putting together a
neighborhood and somebody needs you know
where the post box post office box is
going or like if a mail truck is coming
through how to get it through like the
you know give it the best directions
right right
uh
yeah he deals with like uh can you build
here is this a flood land or you know
[ __ ] like that and
but yeah i'm the only one that even took
to like something artist-driven or
creative-minded
so when did it start to like really take
shape or something or what do you think
kind of
did you have some pitfalls or something
like what was it like in your teen years
growing up because i know you got into
some trouble right yeah yeah i got into
a little trouble so
the other side of my father
that
was the side that i seen the most more
than the hard-working salesman was he
was a hustler yeah so my father booked
bets on the side most of his life you
know it's part of part of a story that
he didn't tell because later in life he
went on to marry a [ __ ] methodist
minister and
totally different dude than the dude i
grew up with you know which i love both
versions of him but i grew up with the
old gangster that booked bets you know i
grew up on a barstool with him booking
bats and
and what bets on anything football games
all kinds of stuff he ran like the old
school football cards yeah so he wasn't
just like a gambler he was the dude who
booked him so we he'd drop off football
cards to like stanley street bar and
larry's and antioch and tgi friday's in
antioch when it first opened up and like
all these local bars he would run
football cards through him and he he
take foam beds to parlays and you know
flat i remember the card i remember my
buddy's dad worked over at like a ford
dealership right and he'd come home
sometime he'd give us a car you know we
could you know we'd put four five six
dollars on it or something that's when
five or six dollars was a big deal yeah
especially for you just to be guessing
it was gonna work and
you know he made a deal with all of us
brothers when we were younger that you
know he said i'll give you a choice i'll
either pay you per football card that
you put out
or
i won't pay you per football card and
i'll let you share in the revenue of it
so his thing was like either you can
take this risk and make more money with
me
or i'll just give you a flat fee for
every you know x amount of dollars per
football card you put in the streets
so he kind of taught us that work ethic
and it was fun to watch the brothers
because you have some that played it
safe
you know and then you had the me's and
that's when he knew something was going
to be different
me and another brother we had some
cousins to play to save me and all the
brothers went for the risky you all
risked me and all brothers were like nah
[ __ ] that we're going for it you know
what i'm saying like we're putting it
all on the line we're trying to upsell
people on bats you know
and trying to figure it out so i always
had that hustler in me and then when mom
and dad divorced i stayed with mama you
know what i'm saying because i feel like
she was the one that needed me yeah but
you know in hindsight as a kid i should
have never you know i should have went
with where i should have went with what
i needed not what i thought somebody
else needed but but that just says your
nature as a human problem yeah yeah for
sure i love my mom i thought my mama
needed me so i was like okay now i gotta
be the
and i didn't learn enough about football
you know who's i was [ __ ] 14 like 15
16 years old i can't go book bets yeah
so i was like yeah
right yeah it's like i'll just [ __ ]
you know i'll go you know
whatever i'll just go find alternate
means of money and for that it was you
know drugs and drugs normally lead to
robin and
you know just goofy [ __ ] as a kid i just
got in a lot of trouble i ended up in
juvenile for a lot of years and
the juvenile years rolled over and
because i went to juvenile you know i
think the first time i was like for 13
or 14 and just kind of went to that
revolving door and looking out
penitentiary ended up in group homes
kept running from them
what was that penitentiary like was it
pretty what anything you miss about it
dude no the [ __ ] no man i tell people
all the time jail
prison
all that stuff dude is when people are
like i love when dudes are like we just
i just talked to uncle joey about this
old joey coco yeah and we were talking
about how some dudes go to prison enough
that they start talking about them like
they're malls
you know what i mean like yeah that
one's actually had really good food and
yo you know that one had the prettiest
guards and i'm like this ain't a [ __ ]
mall they all sucked that one had an
american eagle like my best memory in
jail
sucks compared to my worst memory at
home you know what i'm saying like when
you're like what was the best day you
ever had in jail it's like i came back
and the whole unit threw me a birthday
party i was working in the kitchen and i
came in and everybody had like put all
their snacks together and they'd set up
a big jelly roll birthday party because
i was going home soon so like a going
away
birthday party and as
much as my soul was touched for all
these [ __ ] gang bangers and criminals
to celebrate me
it sucked you know what i'm saying it's
like you know like the worst birthday
i've ever had at home [ __ ] swamped
that one you know what i'm saying google
surprise party in prison
i didn't want to get an image in my head
and did they have any uh let's get a
couple images there let's see something
yeah let's see if this even pops up
let's see oh there's probably a band
called it i'm sure there is that's the
problem nowadays you google anything
there's some shitty band named after it
oh for sure yeah yeah we're not getting
much
no if we didn't have camera phones in
there
oh
right there click on that cake
yeah happy birthday jamal now imagine if
somebody made it
yo jamal happy birthday you know the
best part of that is if they would have
made that out of honey buns it'd be
realistic right that'd be some stuff
because you know you get a canteen in
there and stuff oh cause y'all had to
make bootleg cakes yeah dude look but i
tell you what because of that my fat ass
can whip boy
i can make something out of next to
nothing now so you'd be in there like
where what was your space in the
penitentiary environment what what kind
of guy were you just kind of the guy
making everybody laugh are you the were
you kind of a hard header what kind of
oh dude i was just dude i guess i
probably made people laughed and
entertained we did freestyle fridays and
i worked in the kitchen and you know
yeah i was just there dude my young
juvenile years i was more of a hard head
because i was the only white guy there
and i felt like i had a point to prove
so you know whatever and did they ever
let you say the n word or not uh you
know what's crazy is that is a word
in which context right because there's
one way in which you're never allowed to
say it right no matter what yeah yeah
and you know another way you know
there's certain white guys that yeah for
sure in different different
penitentiaries and prisons every now and
then somebody yeah
yeah sure they'll let you get away with
it just you know you just want to make
sure you don't have a neighbor recording
or nothing you know yeah that stuff will
stick with you
i'm saying
shout out to our boy but now i'm just
joking bubba but you know it's like you
want to make sure that
yeah no they don't you know it's
different man it's also different per
jail every jail and every prison and
everything has a different structure you
know it gets way more racist in federal
prison than in state prison and it's
especially like county jails is a
totally different world because you know
everybody yeah when you go to the county
jail there's like a degree of separation
between you and everybody in the county
oh wow yeah because it's all it's local
it's all local like worst case scenario
you're from north nashville we're two
minutes away from me dropping somebody's
name in north nashville that we both
know yeah you know what i mean the other
problem with that is it's a lot of real
drama in there though
like where guys have been like i have
been waiting to run into you because you
had a problem with my cousin oh you know
whatever year yeah you know oh yeah
that's really that's really the uh
that's the real confluence of the local
[ __ ] yeah where it's like in the
federal scale there's no way me and a
dude in wisconsin ever have a personal
problem with each other right right well
you know in the county jail i had a lot
of personal problems with people and
what about a lot of gays in there any
type of activity like that a lot of gay
activity or was that when you get to
like prison prison you start having
dudes that are you know busting their
butt open yeah but
the county jail that's not happening i
spent more time in the county jail in
the big prison so yeah because i was
more of a revolving door kind of
criminal go for a year or two come home
go for a year or two come home you know
i'm just like a i was that guy yeah oh
he's back you know what i'm saying that
was like somebody that winners in
florida like that kind of yeah exactly
[ __ ] totally right like a guy that
goes to losers you know once every two
weeks or winters oh yeah red i was a red
door kind of guy you know it's like i
was just oh he's back you know and those
are local bars people don't know that
yeah yeah yeah sorry um super nashville
talk y'all so what about uh so when so
when you kind of got when music kind of
got
kind of took over your life did that
have an effect like tell me kind of how
you got
how did you get into the music dan
i was just
i started writing raps young just
because i didn't think i had a cool
voice to sing you know and nobody in the
family sang to teach me to sing so
i would write like raps and that was
obviously like
i don't know how much that we caught
earlier but that was the language of the
community hip-hop was the language of
the neighborhood you know a super mixed
community i grew up like you you know
what i'm saying like it always is a poor
neighborhood man it's really because
black [ __ ] is cool usually
so it's like black [ __ ] always is the
cool [ __ ] right 100 no
it's
to this day
hip hop has influenced every genre of
music on earth
for other people won't admit it or not i
hear it the most in country music yeah i
mean i hear hip-hop melodies hip-hop
drums 80h that is just so prevalent in
country music but
you know hip-hop was the language of the
community so
that was kind of what i got into first
night freestyle at tables and in
juvenile freestyle battle people and i
tell this story it's my favorite story
to tell about my father i was going
getting bound over as a juvenile and
charred as an adult i had made a
decision as a child that they warranted
me being charged as an adult and i ended
up with that felony on my record for a
crime i committed at 16 to this day i
can't get rid of that felony
and
when they bound me over the only good
thing that happened was i got a bond i'm
17 years old i'm going to the county
jail they let me call
one person when i get to the county jail
and who was it pops 100 of the time i'm
calling my dad i'm calling he answered
one man that was my guy the dude
supported me more than i can tell you
buddy's stories till i'm blue in the
face he was the most supportive dude
of my wild [ __ ] of anybody when i wanted
to quit music probably six years five
six years ago
i sat down with him for seven years ago
and i was like pops
i'm just i'm not it's not gonna work i
was sitting at the tin roof a bar right
on the monroe street that they have a
plaque with his name in there he was a
legend at the spot yeah this is
nashville yeah this is a super beautiful
spot right under mine we ever come
through swing through
and uh they serve everything out of
plastic i would say beautiful it was not
the term i would use for but it is a
good spot
the higher floors you go it gets
extremely sticky until you get you can't
even leave i don't think the fourth
floor oh yeah oh you're talking about
the broadway oh yeah i'm thinking i'm an
old-school og demombrian right okay
that's right there yeah oh yeah that one
is nice yeah and everything's served out
of plastic which was [ __ ] what my dad
thought was the greatest because he'd
take a drink to go with him every day
you believe in stem cells well i don't
know anything about them dude hell
you're did you be
way beyond my pay grade of intelligence
at this point
i want to get hair plugs is that close
to the same thing or not you're doing it
um
no you're doing fine i think on the hair
man i'm hurting up
listen man my fear in life is balding is
it i can't be fat and bald
you know what i'm saying dude listen dog
when you're fat you got to pick
struggles very intelligently theo really
yeah man i don't get to be you know you
can have a kind of a smelly day and get
away with it because you're an old
handsome [ __ ] not me damn if i'm fat
and smelly it sticks forever i got to
make sure i'm smelling my dog yeah if
you wake up forget deodorant should i
open a little musty i'll wake up forget
deodorant that'll log it's a damn
ecosystem i'll do it i will it will
follow me like pig pen oh
yeah cause you're a bigger guy man
what's it like being bigger well you got
to make sure every chair won't hurt you
or break you you look first well you've
got to give it a test you know what i'm
saying for sure you got to ease into it
yeah man damn i don't think about that
kind of stuff and were you always a big
guy since you were young yeah dude i was
fat as a kid man i've just always
struggled with like
and i think it's a part of my my
personal mental health struggles right
we all have our own things and our own
demons and vices and for me
i could literally go on a three-day
cocaine bender right now and wake up on
the fourth day and be like well that was
a lot of fun and not do it again for
weeks or months you know
but dude you [ __ ] set some snacks out
somewhere and don't let me hover around
more than two or three minutes i'll
start filling my pockets up like i'm in
jail and i'm never gonna see them again
yeah i'm saying like for sure you want
them snacks yeah yeah i'm all about
snacks
do you um
does it scare your way does it worry you
yeah all the time dude i don't want to
be this fat i don't want people
commenting on who's going to die it's
going to happen for sure you know what i
mean oh damn right
it might be me writing it too
i got a couple of ghost accounts ghost
accounts you know it's like you don't
want to go through that and yeah i'm on
the i got a nutritionist now i've been
working on working on my weight this
year more than i have in a long time
but i also don't worry about as much as
i should because i've been on this
roller coaster my whole life where i'm a
little more plump right now but i can
show you pictures when i was less plump
and i could show you pictures when i was
more plump i just kind of you know it's
kind of part of what i what i deal with
just trying to get on the other side of
the mountain do you feel like um
well what two questions have you ever
tried any like because i know they do a
lot of those surgeries and so if you
ever done anything like that where they
like get into your system or whatever
yeah i'm just not with that don't you
know i'm not gonna i don't know man
don't [ __ ] don't get cut on and all that
old [ __ ] yeah
i just don't know what people do you
know you know what the most selfish
thing i can say right now is what's real
i've heard when you do the surgery it
[ __ ] with your ability to intake
anything
which i would love for that to be the
case with food but like they were like
well you can't drink more than a half
gallon of water a day on or it'll make
you sick
what like i don't want to spend my life
i'd rather die young yeah not young like
this but like you know than having to
measure your water you have to measure
my water you know what i'm saying like
just little stuff like
yeah when they started explaining some
of the stuff to me because i went and
talked to the dude you know what i mean
like there's no there's not a fat person
on earth that can afford the surgery
that hasn't at least went and talked to
the person about the surgery yeah you
know and when he started explaining it
to me i was just like and he was honest
enough too he's like look man
i think that if you just put your mind
to it you'll lose the weight again it's
been proven that you can lose the weight
what hasn't been proven is that i can
keep the weight off
so that's what we gotta figure out next
that's such a struggle for so many
people man you know i i i don't know
what that's like i know what it's a
struggle is like but i don't know what
that struggle is like do you feel though
also
you're so recognizable as this like
larger than life character
do you feel like being larger
you almost have to be larger no it's
like
i think the real side of it is
it's a decision to live
and i'm just starting to make that
decision
i spent most of my life yeah not giving
a [ __ ] if i live or not just not giving
a [ __ ] i feel that yeah i tell people to
this day like when i really start to get
angry
i have to i've had to have this moment
with a few grown men in my life where
i'm like dog do i look like somebody
that cares
like you should really assess that
before you talk to me crazy
i have everything written on my body to
show you i don't give a [ __ ] about a lot
you know what i mean it's like i'm just
starting to give a [ __ ] like i'm just
looking at my 14 year old daughter like
i used to be like if i could just live
till she's 18 i'd be okay now i'm
starting to be like i'd like to meet my
grandkids i think yeah you know it's
like you're starting to think about [ __ ]
you didn't think about before and that
kind of magical when those ideas come in
your head that think make you believe
you care about yourself yes that's
insane it's little stuff that's like i
think i do want to meet my grandchildren
yeah so that's what made me higher in
nutrition is before it was like a chore
to be like i just want to stay alive
till she's 18 so i don't create any more
unnecessary trauma in her life yeah you
know what i'm saying and then it's like
you know it's about her and then it's
kind of like selfishly now it's about me
it's like i don't know man i kind of
want to hang out with your grandkids i
kind of want to kind of want to see
where this thing ends up with her yeah i
want to see what jelly yeah when jelly
starts to kind of coagulate i want to be
there yeah for sure i want to kind of
look cause like now she's cool enough at
14 that i'm like dude i bet she's gonna
kick ass at 25. i want to see that yeah
you know what i'm saying like oh dude
she's gonna be a whole different human
at 35. [ __ ] i didn't know my ear for my
[ __ ] at 25. wait till she's 35 i'm
like [ __ ] i gotta live for 30 years not
20. you know what i mean like oh god
damn i need to
oh dude complete accident really yeah
man for sure and was it like a one-night
stand deal or were you i don't know i
was on and off with the girl for a long
time man uh uh well until one of them
one of my cycles of jail i had bailey
when i was in jail okay you know what i
mean was kind of my thing so
and did you uh was it your first
girlfriend was it was he the mother of
the child
yeah well not my first girlfriend but
you know or one of my earlier earlier
girlfriends believe it or not to be a
big fella i've always fancied myself
with women yeah
you know wife is a real
your wife got them hammers on her baby
look at front yams
she is a stacked deck
and she is a [ __ ] sweetheart of a
woman
and she's a [ __ ] pitbull when she
needs to be i married a full-blown
german shepherd
she she mixes the pot perfectly but i've
always my wife tells people this is like
i love when she gets with people
wondering like she she's a gold digger
like i was piss broke when i met bunny
she financially supported me for years
yeah
two and bunny is his wife's name yeah
and bunny got them rabbits
you know what i'm saying mr mcgregor's
guard first time [ __ ] want to
give her the carrot
yeah but and then she'll tell people too
like dude i'm not the first bad [ __ ] my
husband's ever [ __ ] like she's the
first person to tell people like i've
always fancied you know a good
conversation with a nice lady yeah so
that wasn't she so the girl i had a kid
with wasn't my first one she was just
the first one that the pull-out
technique didn't work with oh really
yeah yeah for sure
i got a son too he's almost six oh
really with the bunny no no
not different relationship they kind of
co-excited there but uh i just i this
girl was pregnant we wasn't together and
i didn't really know much about the
situation with the pregnancy like you
know whatever yeah i knew she was
pregnant and i knew it was mine but we
wasn't together at the time she got
pregnant and me and bunny started
courting each other and yeah it's a
longer story but yeah it's not my
favorite story to tell but yeah i got a
son too and he's cool as [ __ ] what about
that first girlfriend you remember that
one her first kiss take me there man
take down a little bit of that adventure
oh dude it's a girl across the street
who always is that you're a girl across
the street too
i think it was dude they had this girl
across the street from me and had that
lloyd christmas on her bruh she was
chipped out you know what i'm saying
she had that sand wedge
that's kind of cute though i thought it
was i'd never seen it yeah you know it
was just damn beautiful her tooth had
that damn cowlick you know
and uh
and some people locked us in a room some
adults and you know perverts really and
they were like watching through the door
and yelling kiss and [ __ ] you
and we didn't know anything about it man
you know and she was the cutest girl
chrissy was her name and she we ended up
so we just kissed you know chrissy i
think that was my first kiss and then
there was another time this beautiful
girl we were playing spin the bottle
dude and i don't even know i i was so
scared to even sit at this circle i was
see we were sitting in the circle
and for years i remember thinking we
were sitting around a fire and then i
just remembered that's how scared i was
i felt like there was a fire in front of
me because some there was a chance there
could be a kiss yes
and this girl named emily man the bottle
stopped on her and i always thought like
somewhere like in the last
uh chasm or whatever in my heart that
she care thought thought about me or
thought you know thought i was you know
a try or whatever i don't know
and she got to pick whoever she wanted
in the circle dude she came over to me
and [ __ ] the fire got you know people
were throwing logs on the fire i'm just
so scared
and i remembered seeing on television i
think on magnum pi
uh
somebody kissed somebody with their
mouth open you know and so that's so she
comes in to kiss me and i just remember
just being like
like opening my mouth up real wide you
know and everybody laughed at me and
she still tried to kiss me kind of but
it was just [ __ ] embarrassing but
anyway man what happened to you wasn't
that cool it was a girl
[Laughter]
it was a little dude i seen the pain i
felt bad for a second i i was a girl
across the street her name was christa
hayes christopher renee
dude i'll tell you this every poor kid
their middle name the girl is renowned
[ __ ] renee
the first shirt i got two nieces from
the same mother and both of his middle
name over there
no those families have middle names like
ours is anne i dated two girls that had
the middle name anne and my daughter
then had the middle name man yeah so
it's [ __ ] it's that my grandmother's
name was margaret elizabeth ann or
margaret dan but renee is that poor and
renee's poor white people dude for sure
yeah it's just kind of gotta feels
razzly dazzling yeah renee
yeah crystal renee hayes especially her
name was haze so i thought the nay in
hayes was cool crystal renee hayes yeah
yeah she was my first kiss man she was a
little blonde girl across the street god
she's cute she was cute as a button dude
she was a little bitty thing and she was
awesome that was my first kiss my first
blow job was outside of a girl's group
home oh yeah i could see that
yeah right
the nudes group home and the girls
groupon was by each other yeah and what
happened you snuck over there yeah but
we used to meet outside and hang out
because we were allowed to hang out
outside and then one day we went over by
the the house where the air conditioning
air conditioning unit yeah right there
by the air conditioner why don't air
condition units advertise you can get
blown behind here best dude dude and
it's the noise kind of you know keeps
you feeling like more cover yeah and if
you [ __ ] on top of it it kind of shakes
and it gives off a little like hot air
oh like that's what we needed you know
how the thing is up top it gets a lot
like it's like a uh like a stove thing
kind of on top of the blow's a little
hotter oh yeah
it is kind of sexy but i went over
japanese i got my first blow job and i
knew right then
that that was [ __ ] the greatest thing
ever oh he was in the blow jobs at that
point oh dude listen i mean i knew that
i was excited to get the [ __ ] and it
was a little let down compared to what
the blowy was oh yeah i'm saying so yeah
[ __ ] ever since then it's kind of you
know the other thing is almost a chore
it's like oh we've got to do that but
yeah there's something interesting about
somebody being willing to admit they're
willing to put their face on your penis
yeah for absolute choice
until the point of it spitting yeah
that whole [ __ ] is just until you get
yeah when you hit pure yeah there's you
know i remember this gal trying to give
me a bj and uh
i mean once well a couple times one time
i was at a party we're gonna sneak off
into the woods
and
the woods we didn't know it was swamp
land right so we're back there
30 40 yards into these woods and it's
like that remember that movie artex and
the swamp of sadness it's just damn
we're up to our necks and damn
i mean leeches i mean who knows i mean
there's no potential i mean mother
nature's blowing me at this point
something's blowing oh yeah you know
what i'm saying there's it's thick where
you're from i could have legit been a
goddamn alligator i couldn't find
anything
it could have been a toothless alligator
boy you know what i'm saying humming nub
down there but i'll tell you this man uh
so we couldn't do it because of weather
you know logistics right so then two or
three weeks later there's a
there's another party so y'all had a
rain delay oh yeah yeah rescheduled the
game the for sure
ah think about it you're fitting to get
your first blow job ref calling it off
the game gets caught off and uh [ __ ]
tournaments
man i mean it was the bear grylls of you
know we were out in the you know it was
damn it was i was getting hungry that's
how long i was out there
so then the next time was another party
and
me and her snuck outside and she starts
to give me some type of a [ __ ] or
something and the girl whose pals it is
the mom
comes out from behind a tree dude
and we're right there
and
she's like what's going on and um i
didn't know what to say and you're like
you know what's going on lady and i i
felt like she kind of should have known
you know but i remember just saying that
uh
this girl was washing my penis i
remember saying
and the mom looked at me like i was such
an [ __ ] for
saying that and i set it off the tip of
my tongue i thought it wasn't that bad
of a thing to say
and uh and she made us go back to the
park she just like you guys go back to
the party and oh she didn't even get to
enjoy it she got rained out the first
time we got [ __ ] the flag on the
plane the second time and then
some guy at school beat me up and stole
her from me no you got that because he
heard she was giving [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ]
yeah oh
damn man yeah the worst feeling in the
world is getting your ass kicked about a
piece of [ __ ] you didn't get
the [ __ ] man
man that time was fun man god it was fun
no i still remember my first hummer it
was [ __ ] absolutely awesome
it was a thing i still remember her name
too it was anita oh yeah really sure oh
yeah anita is an interesting name yeah
it was another one of those spanish lady
no no he was
all american purebred white trash like
myself amen yeah anita i could see that
being that's very much i can see that
being like also a white kind of white
trash name
blue chew you know it blue chew baby
then penile hitters daddy
it's a unique online service
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis
if you want that extra confidence when
it's time for sex when you get in or
doing sex or considering it blue chew
can help
blue chews licensed medical providers
they work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription
you don't like swallowing pills no
problem
the tablets are chewable
chew your way
to that
hearty wang that's right
and guys here's a special deal for you
if you want to get well in that heater
baby try blue chew free when you use our
promo code t-h-e-o to meet up
that's right use promo code theo at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's
bluechew.com
promo code theo to receive your first
month for free
so then how did the music really start
to pop up when did that start to really
bloom in your life you know
when i was incarcerated the last time
all stories go back to this
sadly
um now are you behind bars actually
you're just like in a little room with a
door
well i've always wondered every jail is
different they have some that are
actually like barred you prefer the bars
of the door oh door a little more
privacy
well you know there's a little little
peep window there you know what i mean a
little pie flap they'll hand you food
through if you're locked down or
something and y'all have any sports
groups in there were you as a
relationship yeah i boxed whenever i was
young and uh it's my love for fighting
um and still like as a fight fan a
boxing fan we had a program at one of
the facilities
and they had basketball courts at most
of them but you know what i'm really
good at because of juvenile i'm [ __ ]
forrest gump with a ping-pong paddle
theo really i'm dude i could be in the i
could be an olympian
it's crazy i [ __ ] [ __ ] forced up i am
so i haven't played in years any time we
get drunk and find a ping pong table i
just goddamn going feel it huh pow pow
pow pow pow looks like [ __ ] the fat
serena williams just [ __ ] moving baby
just
i can [ __ ] play ping pong dude
because i wasn't good enough to get on
the basketball court with all the black
guys so you know i just held court at
the ping pong table in juvenile and
i like that that was my thing
but uh yeah but i was the last time i
was in jail jail yeah
and
i knew that bailey was born while i was
incarcerated that's my daughter that's
my oldest that's why did that bang you
up
yeah i mean it [ __ ] with me you know
what i'm saying it was like it was the
most first moment where i realized i
couldn't be selfish
so i was like selfish as far as like i
had a reason to live outside of self
because i tell people all the time
without purpose
jason d ford will drive him he's a train
that's destined to wreck
yeah right it's purpose that drives me
every day it's providing for my daughter
it's making music that helps people
it's helping friends it's building stuff
bigger than myself because i put so
little value into myself obviously right
so at that moment i was like i got to do
something i can't i don't want to be an
absent father i had a very present
father
i didn't want to be an absent father and
i was like i need to you know i need to
stand up and do something here and
i have my skill sets are still to this
day
utterly [ __ ] limited
i mean y'all dude i'm not good at much i
mean ping pong and songs and
talking [ __ ] a little bit and that
[ __ ] yeah and there it stops you know
what i'm saying it's like yeah that is a
short list yeah i'm not gonna win a
talent show or anything like that if i
had to do something other than what i do
now right
and i was like man i don't you know
music's got to be it
so i came home and started putting out
mixtapes i tell you where i got [ __ ]
can i ask him to pull up some can i have
a pull up some moment yeah pull up jelly
roll 10 minute freestyle
my buddy chad arms recorded this
and
he had like a sony flip cam or something
when i first got out
and uh yep right there
and this is the second or third time we
put it up right
um
so
this particular video
was early early to it this was uh we put
this up in 16 but i actually
had it up before
from in like 2 000 and
that's you or nine yeah that's me fresh
out i mean when i say fresh out of jail
like i just got that haircut my homeboy
had just bought me that shirt i can tell
that this is very near a halfway house
because that guy in the hustler shirt is
always with he's always in the
background of every halfway house yes no
for sure dude that guy frank or whatever
yeah i mean i
you know i'm fresh out the lady i was
with at the time bought me a phone i
remember this is how old this was i
referenced the phone because in the
freedom of freestyle i say uh your baby
mama loved me been out of jail for a
week and got a touchscreen it was like a
big deal to have a touchscreen phone
back then for me at least this was like
two the first time it came out was in
2008. let's see that [ __ ] run it up
for a half a pluck and i ain't tripping
that's the real price jelly roll is real
white but still got the coke and it's
real nice it's got a base tip but
sometimes it's real white and you don't
know what
[Music]
yeah so this is it right you should if
you ever got 10 minutes to blow it's
worth watching i was like
fresh out of jail with a lot to say and
we uploaded it in 2008 when i 2000 on my
fault 2009
when i first got home and where does all
that come from so how do you get to this
place though i see that you know like
your mother had issues she probably
maybe had some type of alcoholism or
something you know you said that she had
some issues right right but how do you
get to be this guy you know hip-hop i
was just rapping everywhere i went dude
i was in the county jail hole in court
dude i had guards that would take me to
different units to freestyle people
before eminem did the eight mile movie i
was living the eight mile movie wow
right in jail and then dude i had a guy
named jazz howard shout out to jazz
howard from crosstracks he would take me
to different barber shops and different
projects in nashville and bet ten
thousand dollars cash i could out rap
any rapper in that project so you know
the local barbershop would like send
somebody to the neighborhood real quick
like shoot over there and grab such and
such such-and-such ducky i'd [ __ ] him up
i'd light his ass on fire grab a mouse
mouse dude jazz give me a couple grand i
was like [ __ ] yeah like i was like
in jail the the back to the the jail
story when i come home dad bails me out
i called dad i said dad i need you to
come bail me out i said i'm gonna pay
you back they got a freestyle battle
sunday at this club i need to brought a
hundred dollars so i can enter it i need
you to bail me out give me a hundred
bucks and i'm gonna enter this and i'm
gonna win a thousand dollars yeah he
didn't blink he was like yeah whatever
go do it and i had they had to sneak me
in because i wasn't old enough to get
him it was sunday night outer limits
eric mcinally joseph herbert are running
the promotional company there they sneak
me in i go in win a thousand dollars
right then you must came home showed my
pipes she's like hell yeah son i was
like listen i'm gonna go back and win it
again next week they did it for 10 weeks
for nine weeks i went in there and won
dollars every time true [ __ ] story
and do you i lost one week out of ten
and what cost you that one week you know
who beat me who was this gonna [ __ ]
y'all up you ever seen my boy call hill
on broadway with the drums he sits on
broadway and raps oh and none downtown
downtown nashville on broadway you got
to go see him he's there every weekend
he sets a drum kit up in front of
merchants and he beats and he freestyles
while people are walking by right and he
makes a living doing this
he's the dude that beat me he's the one
dude that beat me and i'm still friends
with him to this day he's on instagram
his broadway rapper but he's my boy and
to this day he's the only one yeah but i
went did i've just always been in the
rap so i came home from jail
uploaded this it [ __ ] went viral back
then we had to take it down because i
have a line in there that says in my pos
i hang drywall yeah and my po made me
take it down
she was like we're gonna violate your
probation you're making a mockery of the
state of tennessee she like scolded me
and i had to take it down so we put it
up many years later but it went what
they called viral back then early early
youtube dude when you had to go you when
you could only get to youtube from a
hard computer yeah you know you need to
have laptops go to desktop type in
www.youtube.com
all the way out yeah all the way dude
you had to hit the ws on there you know
the thing so what uh so now so now
you're at the spot though where you have
the number five song yes sir
and on the rock rock radio rock right
here
so how do you get from where you were
then to now like what kind of happened
take me through some more of it
i fell in love with songwriting through
the process of writing raps
i immediately i was boxed into being a
freestyle rapper okay and i was like i
don't want to be known for that so i
started writing like songs
and all of my choruses were really
soulful and i'd wrap the verses i had a
song called
you pull up rat jelly roll riding all
alone and i had this record called rad
and all alone and it was really slow
and being a little white first of all
the white from three six mafia you
probably remember
yeah
perkins and lower tabs still one of my
best friends to this day and when i
first came from memphis huh yeah yeah
yeah he's memphis as [ __ ] too when i
first came home from jail we did a song
together and juicy j and dj paul ended
up three six mafia producing an album
with me white and a guy named p peasy
but
outside of the first song i put out with
him i started putting out these super
like soulful joints like this
uh maybe go to like the minute mark or
something i just want you to hear the
chorus so you can kind of get a feel for
where i'm coming from here
[Music]
and see this was released in 2010
[Music]
right so this is you know [ __ ] 12
years ago right
i just keep on smoking like [ __ ] it i'm
prepared to die say your prayer cause
lord if you're there right here
watch this check this out
[Music]
yeah but it's like this you know 12 13
years ago right because it went yeah
that would be good and that that that
that would be good and i mean that's
good now yeah so then i didn't realize i
was singing that chorus
right you know what i mean like i didn't
register to me that i was singing
because i wouldn't like open up and sing
it you know what i mean so i kind of
like did this like
talk sing thing because i wasn't
confident in my voice so i've kind of
always knew
and this somehow i'm glad i got to show
this to a platform as big as yours
because
the therapeutic music that i make now
that's so personal has always been my
approach to music
like when you listen to that i'm talking
about doctors said if i don't quit uh
quit living like this i won't live to
see 35 i just keep on smoking like
[ __ ] i'm prepared to die i've always
wrote
from that kind of dark perspective you
know
yeah cause i'll listen to save me
sometimes when i need to feel how
sometimes i'm too busy i notice or too
caught up
to really just get my own feelings out
right and so i'll listen to save me just
to
so somebody else can do it for me almost
in a weird way you know a lot of times i
can get him but sometimes he can't no
that's the beautiful thing of music man
yeah yeah music is uh
music is the soundtrack of the soul
and that's how i've always looked at it
just like tears are the the expression
of words we can't articulate
and i'd look at music as being the
soundtrack to the soul so i've always
wanted to make music that would help
people that song is a great example that
song is [ __ ] 13 14 years old
so i always so the transition has been
very slow
it seems like it happened quick for the
unseen eye because guys now are like
dude it's crazy you're on rock radio
which is [ __ ] crazy to me too but
the idea that like you know we've always
leaned that way i just didn't know i
could sing
five six years ago i started like really
singing i got drunk and went and sang
but you gotta you gotta you gotta go to
karaoke song yeah i do um
actually i do rocking around the
christmas tree right i do a christmas
carol because i'm not that great of a
singer and um
everybody likes it everybody first is
like [ __ ] this guy you know queer you
know but then like 10 seconds into it
they're like you will get a scent you
know
so it's like nobody can really super
hate on a christmas carol so i played a
safe bet right no dude it's awesome
but what i love about that is i tell
people we all secretly have a go-to
song we sing in those moments you know
karaoke thing oh i wish mine was that
smashing pumpkin song bro
you know what my god that one's good
mine is and has always been old-time
rock and roll by bob singer just take
those old records off that's ain't that
interesting oh that's it that's it for
sure yeah 100 percent it's crazy right
it's like the song stuck in every white
trash human's mind forever but it's uh
and you forget it's there and then it
packs his little [ __ ] head out and
you're like yeah [ __ ] i do know that
song
look it'll help you finish cleaning the
kitchen i know that [ __ ] bro i won't
slide around in my socks yes my mom used
to put on brian adams she got one of
those cassette tape deals where you give
them 30 cents and they send you six
cassettes or whatever and then you don't
pay them and they sue you right
so we had that deal and one of them was
brian adams yes uh look into my heart
oh yeah and you will see
what
you mean
there we go sing it to us
but mine was oh my mind was old time
rock and roll and i go out with some
business guys one night that i'm working
on a production deal with and it sounds
like drugs yeah
oh yeah it's [ __ ] torturous and and
we're all doing karaoke drunk and i did
bob seger and somebody in the group was
like dude you can really [ __ ] sing
and i don't know why it's all it took
for me to be like maybe i can and i just
started saying i started like really
singing like from my ballsack then you
know at first i was just singing from my
chest and i started singing from my ass
yeah that's when i was like just clinch
my butt cheeks together and [ __ ] open
my little [ __ ]
hips and just [ __ ] bro
[Music]
like a hound the problem is i'm now
having to learn how to sing and work
backwards from there
so it's like trying to do the stable
stuff you know what i mean or yeah the
inflections of lower stuff is like it's
so [ __ ] hard where it's like
just take those little records off
yeah that sounds hard
i uh i want to say this though dude what
about the ladies so you got married
where'd you meet your wife at i know
your wife has a wild story
oh dude my wife is [ __ ]
the [ __ ] best
i met her in vegas at a show and she's
be look i'll say this beautiful lady
i've seen her a couple times she come in
the room she ain't looking at me she's
looking at you oh dude you know you
could tell that wife has dialed into you
no that's my girl man she's she's the
sweetest woman on earth
and uh i met her in vegas and i was
really down on my luck i was living out
of a van i was [ __ ] damn you know
literally i was living out of a
conversion van i was just handed out huh
where were you urinating oh dude just on
the side of the freeway same place i was
[ __ ] you know truck stops and you
know we were doing 250 years old dude
flying j's in love stay away from tas
tas are the [ __ ] word they're the
trailer park of truck stops i've been
saying that dude a friend of mine
reached in they had a
live fishing well or something in there
at one of them
meningitis from the damn tank in there
but i will say this though he [ __ ] i
do remember he dropped a laffy taffy in
that [ __ ] and he reached in it [ __ ]
got himself some part of that's on him
baby
you know what i'm saying
if you eating candy out of my aquarium
at a truck stop oh dog that look the
lord he gets to do what he wants nothing
is trashier than a ta yeah if i wake up
on the bus and wear the ta i'm just like
[ __ ] me man how old happened i can't
even open my bowels up at a damn ta bro
but you get me over to a flying j you
get me to a loves what i love about
loves dude if you're using the urinal or
the [ __ ] in there you can [ __ ] and
hear somebody play buck hunter right
outside the door oh for sure dude pilots
are [ __ ] awesome as well yeah they're
pretty good the apple barns or whatever
they're called
west coast they're kind of trash
but yeah so we were like doing 200
something shows a year
and it's like wow so you guys were on
the road man dude i was opening for
everybody i mean i went out with the
insane clown posse but the first people
that ever took me a little white out was
a group called twisted they were signed
to icp at the time
great dudes man skinny puppy you ever
got with them no but i do well with
mushroom head the metal band
they're [ __ ] fire when i love a
picture of them mushroom head yeah yeah
yeah this is awesome skinny in them on
this icp tour one time i was the first
active five so i didn't have a like
dressing room or nothing and that means
i went on when people were like you know
still walking in the door and buying
popcorn and stuff yeah totally yeah it
was the worst setup worst set ever
and this band invited me gave me the
code to their bus and they would let me
use their bus as my green room and i'm
forever grateful to skinny in this band
to this day we're friends because they
were so good to me and dude i had a
1994 conversion band like a southern
comfort high top
and this 1990 something 95 96 i got we
called it bertha and everybody who
toured with me back then has birth a
tattooed on them shout out scary larry
and the crew they all casey strums they
oh yeah that's it that's my van i feel
like that white one down there with the
high top i know on the left left left
left left right there right yep the
white one boom that is [ __ ] bertha
son wow that is big bertha to a [ __ ]
curtains in the window it might be a
picture yes sir it did that might be a
picture in my van we hung a tv up in it
scary larry and casey hung up a tv me
and highlight would sit back there and
[ __ ] watch [ __ ] old dvds and stuff
today that'd be damn homeware erotic
yo the bat we have we carried a trailer
on it so the back seat would lay down to
a bed
kind of like a futon or something and i
lived in that [ __ ] theo like
[ __ ] when i met my wife well i was like
i was like come let's smoke a blunt in
the van and she got in a van and she
said again to this day she tells story
gave her anxiety because it was so
trashy it like smelled like [ __ ] [ __ ]
and cigarettes it was like you know it
was [ __ ] sick people been doing
coming in there coming in there cocaine
in there [ __ ] i think some guys were
tying their arms off it was bad we were
struggling out there man it was a rough
run dude for us the devil's tug awards
bertha dude everybody's got birth of
tattooing have you toured with me in
that area you got bertha tattooed on you
god dude that's when two was so
different there was before before uh
smartphones it was just you were just at
the will of the world oh dude 50 a night
is what i got paid for like three years
straight
like 50 bucks a night we didn't have
enough room to get gas and a hotel yeah
so it was like we just had to go [ __ ]
park at truck stops and sleep some
nights you know we were banging on merch
we were counting on hand-to-hand cds and
t-shirts dude how'd you used to do them
i'll tell you this i used to break so i
remember once at one point i bought that
burner baby
three shelf burner bruh from the cds
i think i was in damn up near cannon and
somebody run that [ __ ] across the
border still like sweat on the outside
of it really he told the city burn of
the tower right three cds at one time
burn three and then it took about 19.
and then we'd put them on a spindle i'd
hand right on every [ __ ] one of them
dude and i would sell them right off the
spindle and i'd make a title of a
different title like they were different
albums no for sure we did that for fun
or we'd autograph them or have the
friend homie autograph some it was just
like and we'd sell them off the spindle
like we wouldn't even give you a case
for them just be like right off the
spindle this is yours for three dollars
you know or five dollars or whatever i
could i used to do it for donations
and hopefully somebody give me some more
money i'd be like look man i'm just
[ __ ] i got 40 bucks to open this show
like i remember a lady one time in fort
worth texas come up and give me a
hundred dollars she's like my husband
just died
really she gave me a hundred dollars for
the for one of the cd's off the spot
just gave it she didn't want the album i
don't blame her wow she was like i don't
really
i'm not into your art i'm just into your
hustle i think about how many people
bought the cd and never listened to it
oh i think like the guys in manhattan i
want to say thank you to everybody that
everybody that bought
sometimes i think it was a dvd dude i
don't even know what was on that [ __ ]
but i sold them and thank you man yeah
no for jeff we did it and i was at that
phase of my life when i met bunny and
she was like this is like she like
adopted a little pound puppy and where'd
you meet her at where were you guys at
we were at this bar called the las vegas
country saloon on free monster a lot of
titles in one yeah pretty big the las
vegas country saloon and fremont street
and bunny was doing high-end escort
stuff she was a sex worker in vegas and
she was getting a
lot of money i mean she had like a real
big plush penthouse and we had a sex
worker on the podcast one time oh dope
you should get money on her one time
she'd love to tell her story she has a
podcast when you get on her podcast too
it's called dumb blonde podcast he just
in here theo i need to plug my wife
podcast we'll put a link to it yeah yeah
she's crushing man and uh she's like on
on apple she's always like the top 10 on
the comedy chart she really kills
but uh bunny just just took me under you
know kind of took me under her wing and
and
you know what was it about her
i think she was just
it was like a genuine thing the moment i
met her like i just knew
she was a you could feel the genuineness
from her and she was in a very ungenuine
business right like that business is
slimy oh yeah it's a lot of shucking
it's a lot of game being ran on both
ends she's running game they're running
game it's just a lot of game happening
it was just i could just feel the
authenticity in our and her though i
just like i hate to be the cliche like i
felt it it was soul mates at sign but i
felt that for real bubba like i felt
that connection with her and she did too
and how did you convince her to do it
because if she's living this lavish
light you know she's living a more
lavish life as a lot of those
you know a lot of sex workers if they
get dialed in on their business and
their business women as well or
businessmen if they gay workers
then they get you know they do real well
you know so how did you get her i mean
if she stops in that van i think damn
this [ __ ] smells like repossession
out of there bruh nah dude she was like
damn bruh no we got ghosts of freaking
people jerking off in this [ __ ]
and i roll up and have any business
sense the last thing i'm doing in that
van is following him
the absolute last thing
i freaking leave one of my legs in that
[ __ ] she picked up a [ __ ] straight
pit bull she said it was she said her
attraction was i was clearly the saddest
human she'd ever met
[Laughter]
i swear to god that's what she said for
us because i'm the second one and she
was like you had the saddest eyes in the
room
i don't know we just connected man it
was like
it felt like a love story that was
supposed to work i mean we're talking
about a woman
you know we're talking about an ex-drug
dealer and an ex-prostitute get together
and build what we've built together you
know a woman who has a podcast it's
crushing a big patreon she does she
still does the only fans thing and
absolutely just [ __ ] that and crushes
that to death and then you know i went
on to [ __ ] dude i'm sitting here talking
to
[ __ ] theo vaughn on a podcast that i
spoke into existence two calendar years
ago yeah right i didn't know you from
the man on the moon you just moved to
nashville what almost two years ago or
whatever and i was like it has been
almost a year and a half
at least a year and a half and i banged
your immediately i didn't know from the
man on the moon i was like yo i'm from
here like i need to get on the cast you
know and here i said it's like not just
because you're hearing my story because
i consider us homies yeah like you're my
boy you know what i'm saying like we're
just talking about some [ __ ] we talk
about the [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] green room of zany's
right now right yeah
and it was funny too it's like you can
sometimes people are like i want to be
on this and that and sometimes it just
works out how it works out it's like
sometimes you almost just have to have a
time for me anyway where you where you
feel like oh this person is in my life i
want to talk you know i saw you the
other night at brennan's show and i was
like man i just seen you a few times
where you know we've seen each other in
different places
and i'm like man every time
that guy is just people want to be
around that guy you know that guy just
lights up the [ __ ] room i just love
people dude man yeah and they love you
oh dude i love them and i love you
but it's like who would have thought
that me and bunny's story would end up
you know where it's at and i think she
did before i did yeah and i think that's
why she took the [ __ ] you know the
[ __ ] pound puppy in she was like i
think she had even the vision i didn't
at the time you know oh yeah he was
drooling dude it was like romeo and
juliet baby you know what i'm saying
didn't pick bonnie bunny picked me yeah
she's the man in the situation for sure
i was just like yes i'll go out with you
yeah and that's just kind of how it
worked and that's awesome yeah we've
been together you know i think six years
going on seven years now
and do you think y'all will have a child
or not i don't think so i don't think
that's something that's in our you know
bunny didn't have a desire to birth a
child
but she always had a desire to be around
children so i think that we kind of fed
each other's needs i got custody of my
daughter
right when i met bunny dude you know
when somebody's poor when they grow up
foreign white when somebody says i have
custody
getting the word
custody it's the hair bro that's the
most
that was
you know
i don't like telling this part well i
want to tell i think she appreciates it
now her mother had a battle with a
heroin addiction but uh bailey's mother
my daughter
and she's sober now and back in bailey's
life which is awesome that's amazing but
at the time it was bad i mean like you
know really really really true addict
stuff bad so i was getting custody of
bailey at simultaneously
courting bunny all while some other
girls like in week three of being
pregnant wow so it's like a really weird
moment where bunny had every reason to
run yeah and instead she just [ __ ]
that [ __ ] dug her heels and it was like
let's [ __ ] go throw me the fastest
pitch you can big boy i'm gonna catch it
and we immediately you know took got
custody of bailey she started raising
bailey as her own to this day bailey
calls
bunny mama and calls her mother mom
so you know and her mother was in a
same-sex relationship she's gay so the
other girl that raised bayley from birth
is a part of it too so bailey's got
three months bam you know what i mean
yeah dude just [ __ ]
that's the limit yeah it's a thing dude
i mean it's a big legal limit i think a
lot of us i'm the only testosterone in
the room besides bunny because she's a
little aggressive sometimes but it's all
[ __ ] [ __ ] and me but it works out
great
do you have well there's tell me about
one of the toughest times you guys had
on the road was there you guys party
pretty hard i'm sure was there a night
where you didn't think he was gonna make
it any night you end up at the hospital
yeah i had a
cause i had a night man it's a few years
back
this is more than a few years back now
but i was like sitting there and i was
so close to going to the freaking
emergency room my heart just
just rattling baby just you know like so
like a cheerleader was shaking that
[ __ ]
mine was codeine so it was the opposite
damn it was going so slow
that between breaths i would hold my
breath for a second and put my my thumb
up to my throat or behind my ear to see
if i could just catch a light poop
boop and i was like i thought i just
drank too much cough syrup and i thought
it was over
how much did you drink it what was it
yeah no no no dude we were doing you
know we were getting we were getting the
real active actors and you know we were
going for we were mixing the potions and
oh wow sometimes we just get the
straight pink the codeine or you know
just the straight you know what
sometimes we get the purple but we you
know we do we were doing
you know 8 10 12 ounces just filling up
put dropping fours and sprites every day
and just getting them gone before noon
and then i'd be so low i'd from that
[ __ ] four ounces or six ounces or
eight ounces of codeine i would [ __ ]
do some blow to pick myself up and then
i'd take a xanax to try to go back to
sleep you know and that's what i tell
people too when they're like you need to
worry about your health i'm like trust
me man i'm gonna live a long longer life
than y'all think i have changed my ways
dramatically when people see me out
drinking a lot they're like you're fat
and drink a lot i was like i used to do
eight balls of cocaine after eating
codeine for breakfast and i would
balance it out with xanax
[ __ ] you i was a molotov cocktail of
death that didn't kill me i think a
little obesity will be okay while i'm
currently working to lose the weight
karen i'll be [ __ ] all right okay i
don't need you worried about my heart i
have a cardiologist [ __ ] i'm fine i'm
losing weight you should have seen me
when i was just running around like my
drug of choice used to be more who was
saying that was my drug of choice like
what's your drug of choice what you got
[ __ ] oh yeah what do you have the
most of
my favorite weed was uh
cocaine
[Laughter]
that was it dude yeah for sure they were
like damn baby only person that could
smell that is you yeah yeah
um
guess what my dad would start doing
what's that this is a god rest his soul
he would get a couple drinks and then he
would walk to the back of this bar
and he would just be like hey can i just
i just need a cup and i'd give him a cup
and they had an ice machine in the back
and he'd go fill up his own cup and then
get in the car and pull out his bottle
from under the
he mixed his own drink right there in
the console put his seat belt on drop
the top on his little sebring
convertible put his sunglasses on
he'd have one for the road man
yeah dude he had a sebring man it's they
all when he passed away
you know there wasn't a lot to to divvy
up around the family and uh because his
wife's a [ __ ]
but
what what what we did end up getting i
haven't met her but i know her yeah yeah
right
so but what we did get was his sebring
and i gave that week we have i wasn't
like i was in charge of giving [ __ ] away
but as a family we decided to give that
to scott so his son could have it who's
in college or you know what i mean or
whatever and his the sebring's still
around dude scott scott's one of my
response my two brothers are super
responsible i'm not scott and roger
rogers the old wisconsin next one so
scott has to see bring and
roger just wanted the kentucky derby
stuff because they him and dad used to
go bet on horses together you know and
all the stuff related to the meat
business and i took the pictures of the
clowns but yeah dude the sea brain is
still in the [ __ ] family scott tented
that [ __ ] scott tuned that [ __ ]
up it's nice man it's running that kind
of thing's pimping every time i go see
him down in georgia we'll take the
seabring out to go get a drink hey come
in it bro make it mean something that's
it dude i did lose bertha yeah i'm sad
about that i messed up i missed my van
everything needed to go dude
i put four transmissions in and i put
400 000 miles on it we beat that thing
to death yeah wow on the fifth
transmission i just never went back and
picked it up damn yeah yeah dude i
remember my friend billy conforto dude
who was uh
probably the greatest gay prize fighter
that never
was in like any sanction fights you know
he just he was homosexual but he beat
people up and nobody ever seen it right
yeah it was an obscure thing oh no he
didn't i mean
still i mean still you see some of it
but you never saw it like this dude bro
and he uh
he had he he hired some dude and then
everybody gave him like 1100 to fix his
transmission that dude [ __ ] never
fixed it we went over there to pick it
up finally we opened up the hood and
everything inside of it was gone he beat
his ass didn't it yeah he did
he did dude the guy thought he could
punk him because he was a gay dude you
know and billy [ __ ] lit him up bro i
know some gay people did every gear
inside of that dude bro i know that i
know uh bailey's other mother cheyenne
uh her baby gays can fight okay listen
cheyenne fights like a dude yeah
bailey's other mom
fights like a [ __ ] dude that gay
women and gay men should fight each meet
in the middle and fight oh yeah for dude
listen i got my money on cheyenne 9 out
of 10 times they used to have foxy
boxing at a strip club in nashville and
cheyenne would show up like a ringer and
just beat the brakes off people dude
we'd show up like a chicken fight taking
bets on the side and cheyenne would just
be in there fanning [ __ ] people out
it wouldn't be fair because the girls
being there bouncing with their titties
they looking all cute and shine was just
coming they're just [ __ ] blind
just swinging from the goddamn shoulders
all hip action dude looking like [ __ ]
a karate oh yeah
yeah she would just dude
they used to have a group called [ __ ]
fist fights right
yes and it was gay it was a gay men
group and they came to different college
towns and they put boxing ring at a bar
and the me and gay men would fight you
know and they would you'd buy you pay
five dollars whatever you get in and
these dudes would fight bro i'd pay a
thousand dollars for a ringside table
one of those right now it was crazy man
i can't believe they used to come to
hammond louisiana they'd roll through
probably twice a year and we go over
there and watch [ __ ] wrestlers come
through too we never i always heard
about that but i never saw that kind of
[ __ ] you know i do yeah we got it here
at the fairgrounds every other month
yeah it was the best
it was there was no fair
they have this thing at the evening
where you run out of this place
dude these [ __ ] midgets dude would
[ __ ] we're going to be politically
correct now [ __ ] that they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude then they call themselves
mitch it's called [ __ ] wrestling
different ones do the old school ones i
think will will say it but then a lot of
new you know if they're fancier then
we'll say it yeah yeah the fancy midgets
that makes sense the real trashy poor
midgets are like midgets right yeah
these were poor midgets then dude but
they would do like
double gainer backflips off the top rope
yeah it was some [ __ ] that like they
should a couple of them guys should have
went to the wwe
yeah i don't know yeah well i don't
think well wwe missed that whole they
didn't they never got into smaller folks
being in there yeah rey mysterio was
like
the closest thing right yeah because he
was like you know acrobatical i think
they left the acrobatical [ __ ] to
lucha libre wrestling oh you go down in
mexico you see whatever dude is that
what they're called is it lucha libre i
believe it's at the movie
that's i think that's
yeah that wrestling was [ __ ]
people were doing backflips and [ __ ] and
i think that's what the [ __ ] wrestling
was they couldn't break a table i mean
they were so small man you'd have to cut
the table down the middle before they
even got on it yeah they were cheated
off the bottom they would kind of bring
it you know cut sawing three four three
four inches do you know uh was there any
time y'all got hijacked or anything on
the road or robbed
no we never had the deal with nothing
like that
yeah we got not paid a few times we
stole some tvs out of venues and stuff
we've took pictures and art and all
kinds of stuff
[Laughter]
it's just that thing above the urinal
that says when there's a call when
there's a car auction
i stole neon signs you know what i mean
i've done all that stuff i broke a
window at a bar before just like then
they were like we got insurance i was
like but you won't be open tomorrow
[ __ ] i was like [ __ ]
one of my friends can you do youtube
comedian touches uh
neon sign
i think it's our friend jamie lisso did
this
oh uh how much they have all this stuff
now
remember when you could find there was a
nine videos and you could find it every
time yeah now it should be
so lis
i think it's him
oh there it is right there comedian
electrocuted on stage
i just ate three sticks and i'm still
hungry
[Laughter]
it just made threes
[Applause]
no he really birthed him then if he
didn't try it again
that's how enormous pets were kind of
hard though i would have had that would
have had it happened twice to me yeah
for sure i'd have been like no i'd touch
one more time one first sure one more
time just like let me just say i'll be
like that ain't real yeah no i stole a
neon sign out of a bar though did they
ever not pay y'all
i'm trying to think yeah but it was more
like shady stuff usually you had to get
yeah well usually you get with the agent
before you can go get into the clubs
before that it's just weird rooms they
had a guy who would it used to just be
bringer shows like you had to bring
eight people right you know and so you
get there and like you don't have
anybody
you can't perform how did you get picked
up by an agent in your business
i think you just start doing well you
get about 10 minutes going and some
manager sees you and then the manager
connects you with an agent usually you
know
and they'll tell you because you got to
feel like that's got to be a hard
business to break like you just got to
be crushing where did you cut your teeth
at
i cut my teeth a little bit in new
orleans and i cut them mostly honestly
in la you know i moved out there and i
hadn't really performed much and
and i took a comedy class even i went to
a class and people always make fun of
the classes and [ __ ] i went there and
the best thing about the class was i
hated the class i was like i'm better
than everybody in here even though i
wasn't yeah but in my head you know
you're just like oh i'm cool you know
um
and they had um
at the end of the class you got to get
on stage and perform that was the
graduation yes you were in front of a
full room and you got a three minute
tape you got your tape and my tape was
decent then you go around other places
and then
you know next you know it's five years
later and you're you know starting to
travel around and do it and then it's 10
years later and
at that time i think around 10 years i i
thought about quitting i moved back home
for about four or five months really
yeah and literally what encouraged you
to get back
i don't know man i was with it i broke
up my girlfriend and i broke up i don't
know i was at home i was working at a
mexican restaurant
bartending in a mexican restaurant i was
not a good bartender and
uh i broke some equipment and i [ __ ]
i still i might know those people in the
men's honestly but i broke some damn
equipment there one of them margarita
makers you know that [ __ ] i was trying
to put it back together late at night
and i couldn't figure it out
and i broke that [ __ ] and
the guy then they you know they were
upset and i don't know at that point i
felt like
there was no reason for me really to
stay i think i kind of hinged my bets on
this girl kind of so when that fell
apart i felt like i didn't know what to
do and then i went back i guess that's
what happened yeah
who all did you feature for early
oh that's a good question man uh
our feature for this one guy named mark
lundholm
and
sober guy super funny dude but he smoked
cigars right and we got stuck up in uh
notre dame of mishawaka indiana oh yeah
right outside of south bend right
outside of south bend man we even went
over and saw the bar where like rudy
would sit at and sit in the seat and
stuff's real cool
but
we were stuck indoors it's 30 degrees
we're stuck indoors and we're sharing a
little condo our house
and he smoked cigars
and i was like hey do you mind not
smoking indoors and he's like i'm going
to be smoking you know and that [ __ ]
would smoke two cigars before he'd go to
sleep i think yeah he's just lighting
them off each other yeah yeah and if i'm
wrong mark i'm sorry but that's just how
i remembered and
you know daddy got tom rhodes too who i
love who i gotta have on here sometime
and when he used to smoke marvel reds
and he and i had to share a place in
shreveport one time and i remember i
asked him i said hey man we might not
smoking indoors he goes i'm gonna smoke
it i think he lit one right right up
then he might have lit two up
he lit two up i think he made me hold
one one more question because i gotta
ask while i got you yeah why did you
probably tell it a thousand times what
was your worst or most memorable bomb
i mean i've had one that i've told where
i just kept i bombed and they didn't
know that i had to come back out between
each act it was like a battle of the
bands
so they booed me off in the beginning
and i burned my material so fast because
it hated me
but i had to keep coming back out
and it was horrible dude at one point i
came out with an american flag like
left
and i had to do like another probably 20
minutes right
and the best part was towards the end i
would kind of sneak like i was going to
come back out and like there's no way
he's coming back out you know and i'll
just come back
[Music]
and they would just die laughing because
they couldn't believe bro one time i
went out and saying smooth criminal i
didn't even [ __ ] know the
[Laughter]
i didn't even know the [ __ ] words
and that [ __ ] man oh but at the time
wrote her i felt
bad even asking them to pay me i just
wanted to leave
and it's such a dichotomy of leaving a
place when you've crushed it and that
feeling of bravado and i did good
then that other feeling of leaving when
you did not and still having to get to
your vehicle get to lee and you know
you're going to run into people
and you just feel that energy
people just turned it out so
jelly roll man i appreciate the time man
i feel like we covered a lot of stuff to
you
you feel like we covered a lot of stuff
i love it dude [ __ ] yeah if when you
frankenstein i think it'll be the
funniest [ __ ] ever
what is it
i don't even know
oh i don't know either man
i'm just trying to stay alive jamie got
a damn electrocuted brother
that s-u-c-k-s baby
that sucks
um dude thank you so much so now you're
on tour so just tell us where you're at
now you know yeah man here goes my
shameless plug um because you've had
this on me you've had a lot of the songs
that hit what what really started to
catapult you then let's get to that save
me
yeah yeah there was a lot of like that's
what i tell people everything i did was
a step on the ladder
save me was like skipping 10 steps on
the ladder yeah you know i know your
story and you save me now it even it
it's more it means
it's under more yeah it's like i could
bore you with like every little step
that helped and there was so many
everything mattered is what i tell
people everything you're going through
right now in your career if you're a
young up an aspiring artist comedian or
whatever every one of those little
things matter and then there's like a
small tipping point that happens like
the malcolm gladwell book where [ __ ]
just kind of save me for me will always
be that moment of like
you know what it's fun i don't know how
it is in your business but it's always
the [ __ ] you don't think is going to be
it yeah dude we [ __ ] wrote save me on
a sunday we recorded save me on a monday
we shot a video to some no but we were
quoted saturday recorded it sunday shot
the video monday put it out tuesday
wow
that's how that worked
didn't think twice about it
and did you know that it would be that
you did you know did you have an inkling
you honestly have any idea i just knew
that i couldn't quit [ __ ] with it
i just knew that it was something about
it that just stirred my spirit
and i was like hype just man we gotta go
for it and i just
i was proud of it
i was like to me it was like a therapy
session publicly
you know and that was like the biggest
thing for me was like just letting those
emotions out
in a public way was like i don't know
some songs i have songs theo that i
wrote that mean a lot to me that i'll
never play anybody ever because they
mean that much to me
and save me was one of those songs that
could have been that song but it meant
even more to me so it was like nah this
one needs to go out like
i just i don't know man i was just
prepared for it to i i loved it so much
i didn't care what it did
if it popped or flopped i just felt like
[ __ ] you know this is the last thing
i'll tell you this story
people
i was talking to travis ogun from
strange music once
we were talking about how
i get thousands of emails a year of
people who say or messages a year that
say your music helped me
i overcame drug addiction i was going to
kill myself and i found your music i was
literally i've had messages that were
like i was sitting there gun loaded
listening to a playlist that was going
to be the last listening of my life
and found a song of yours that made me
feel like man this is it touched me in
such a way
that it changed my decision and this is
my thing if i get
5 000 of those a year
and 4
99 of them are lies
holy [ __ ] can you believe we saved one
[ __ ] human
you know what i mean like let's just
assume everybody's full of [ __ ] but one
[ __ ] guy
holy [ __ ] man you know what i mean me at
the end of the day
that's what saved me was about it was
like man
what means the most to me and that's why
i write the music i write is people come
up to me and oh dude
such and such was fun i love that song i
danced to it but when people come up to
you and say dude we played save me at my
cousin's funeral that overdosed
and it's now his mother's favorite song
and the way she copes with it or we
played smoking section at this funeral
or
we played smoking section to commemorate
this or hey man this song helped me when
i got out of rehab yeah
that [ __ ] is like
[ __ ] what this shit's about dude you
know what i mean like when a
[ __ ] is like dude i don't just
watch your podcast for humor it was the
[ __ ] first thing i laughed at after i
got out of [ __ ] sobriety
like that's the [ __ ] that touches the
soul you know what i mean
yeah a friend of mine recently told me
he said yeah man if you have a story and
you don't share it if you it's that
thing that you're afraid to share you
know it's that scary thing you know
that's the connection that's the thing
that you know that somebody else could
really be waiting to hear you know
there's a reason why there's that
magnetism of uncertainty with you with
with uh with with sharon's stuff
sometimes you know and yeah man it's
wild to help how certain things can have
an effect on people i mean there's songs
i go listen to that
of certain friends that passed away and
i go listen to a certain song and it
reminds me of them it reminds me of him
it reminds me of a
certain times in my life when i cared
about certain things you know it is the
power of a song is really powerful yeah
it'll take you back to a place in time
man yeah dude will take me back to that
freaking that bon jovi song baby yeah
maybe yes baby it'll take you right back
to being in the front seat of that
[ __ ] car for however you felt the
first time you heard it oh it's also the
greatest feeling on earth is when you
hear a song for the first time and the
feeling you get yeah i remember certain
songs in my life that i heard for the
first time and like it just changed
everything about how i thought about
things just one song
yeah don't go chasing waterfalls by tlc
i remember we were driving to the mall
one time and that [ __ ] came on dude
and we [ __ ]
we were never the same
for sure
tim and joey we were never the same we
sang that thing do you have a favorite
song
uh
i got some stuff that we play on the pod
sometimes by evan bartels i love
he's a local singer-songwriter i love
listening to hit some of his stuff
do i have a favorite song you know what
i like right now listen to dirt by
florida georgia atlanta just really like
that song i'll get stuck on the song for
a little while you know
i've been into country music more since
i've been here but i listen i've been
listening to juice world recently that i
really like
um
i don't know if i have a favorite song
do you yeah well i'm one of them weird
dudes that has a top five in every
category of everything i've got i've got
a top five comedy bit list
of like what i think was the best top
five comedy bits
to me personally but songwise number one
as of now they they're subject to change
every now and then is against the win by
bob seger
that song just has told my story and i
feel like it's the story of who i am as
a human what i've been through as an
artist and where i'm at as an artist now
and uh i just remember the first time i
heard that song and just thinking man
this is this is my life and and i still
feel it every time i listen to it so you
got things on to youtube you and then
things started to really pop from there
then when save me came out yeah man it
was just building the youtube and you
know just building just putting out
music oh yeah with those 30-something
million i mean your spins are crazy man
yeah yeah save me said almost a hundred
million now
97 million almost if
some of y'all want to go check it out
gang [ __ ] with me and get me over the
line here look up populations of
countries right now i want to see
what country is listening what country
could have entirely listened to yeah
what country could have everything get
warranted really quick i think when i
looked at it recently it's like one
third of the american population
yeah that's probably about right let's
go to just can you go down is there a
list is there a chart there we go get
that chart let me zoom in a little bit
daddy
let's look at 100 million right there 98
there we go
vietnam holy [ __ ] baby we're close to
touching egypt dude i need to get to the
egypt mark you close baby that would be
fire dude they could have been over
there [ __ ] mummies and [ __ ] bang and
save me the philippines they want if
once you hit philippines baby that is
massive it's crazy that it's more than
the united kingdom that's nuts
that's amazing i never thought about it
like that i think about it from like
football fields yeah you know what i
mean like
that's how i just
like categorized things to me as you
know how many people how many nights
could i sell out a football field if at
that rate you know what i'm saying it
was like 30 nights or something and now
y'all are playing bigger venues now
you're touring yeah i'm throwing the
shine down later this year tickets
actually go on sale they should be on
sale by the time y'all see this tickets
are on sale jelly rolls shine down the
[ __ ] they've had more number ones
than any rock band in history wow i
can't believe i'm going out with them
it's surreal that's amazing it's just
[ __ ] awesome so i'm going out with
shine down later this year i got a bunch
of headline dates
jellyroll615.com you want to come see me
sure you use the support and we're
playing a lot of festivals dude amazing
that's gonna be a blast bro people gonna
love it i got a big announcement coming
from nashville in a few weeks i got to
figure out but you know it but i got a
it's for a mayor for everywhere yeah for
sure not just for nashville no no no i'm
saying you know you they're out now but
i'm saying we're going to announce our
nashville show oh we're going to be back
announcing big announcement about the
nashville show coming up it'll be
it's going to be
insane
it's
never thought this ain't even something
i want to say i dreamed about this i
didn't think it ever happened it was sad
what was that song that bon jovi saying
one of their hits tim who's in here
we've been fighting this all day bizzle
we can't remember the bonjour i had
hours to think about it even after and
[ __ ]
silently still is that bon jovi in the
dead poison okay not them
who was it damn uh
bad medicine
no
look you look a bun
nose before that
let's sing a song for the i don't think
that was it uh
johnny works johnny working down in the
dark
working for a man he can't shorten
[Music]
that's living on the edge baby oh yeah
shoot me
johnny's what we're gonna die
you gotta hold on to what we got it
doesn't make a difference
[Music]
babysitter we're halfway my babysitter
played that it was the first song i ever
remember hearing i went on a prank
because i heard it with a woman i heard
it with a chick and i thought she was
cute and so in my mind that that made
enough glue yeah and so dude i kept me
wearing our car you were living on a
prayer break
i kept saying hey let me put your seat
belt on for you again
we'd be driving i put our seatbelt on 30
times just rubbing my hand across her
chest dude then hopping behind my
buddy's map in the back
y'all were sharing the maps together
oh man we're both headed the same
direction eh
jelly roll thank you so much uh we'll
put the information where people can
come check you out when does the tour
start do you know i head out at the end
of this month to do the east coast run i
think those are all sold out but the big
shine down tour starts in the fall i got
some dates getting announced with a
couple other guys that are big friends
of mine and i'm supposed to talk about
it but i will because i don't care i'm
going out and do some shows with cole
wetzel our boy oh yeah yeah i'm doing
this i gotta help
me and co wetzel got a song coming out
later uh that's really dope um called
role model aka the cocaine song and
um yeah i got some [ __ ] cooking man it's
gonna be a big year for me dude i'm it's
it's surreal we're like doing full
amphitheaters all year it's crazy
dude that's amazing red rocks red rocks
is on sale right now there's only a
couple thousand tickets left we went on
sale a few days ago and there's like
1700 tickets left i would be i would cry
if i could hurry up and sell them just
to have the piece you know i sold out
the [ __ ]
top two most legendary venues in america
that'd be fascinating man yeah code's
unbelievable code is just a i mean he's
that he's a
he's that [ __ ] you texas rock country
southern he's like me you can't really
label what he does anything it's just
different you know yeah
he is
what is the word i'm looking for it's
he's a rebel yeah no for sure dude it's
polarizing he's a rebel man yeah he's a
rebel man dude he's like he's like me he
does not give a [ __ ] he's one of my
favorite people in music
well [ __ ] him and we'd be happy to have
him in here sometime um
[ __ ] you because we'll have to have him
in here sometimes jelly roll thank you
so much man and congratulations on all
this success and just thanks for sharing
your story man uh i can relate to
certain chapters of it and um
yeah it just seems uh
it seems like you
what you're creating is just part of
your life man it's cool to see thank you
for watching bro thank you for having me
i love you man it means the world yeah i
love you too bizzle gibbons tour
managers thanks for stopping in riley
mao peeked in before we had to go to i'm
sorry some type of church meet up
and uh nilo sat in today to help produce
so thank you guys so much gang gang
gang
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna
take a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself all mine
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
mine
[Music]
now